القليل
[موسيقى]
في العشرين من العمر ، لقد سئمت من رفض حلها
مرحبا مراسل
أوه هذا صعب
بعد أن قلت أنني يجب أن أشارك في عمل خبيث ، إذن
قابلت إكسبو شور في دا
بدون هذا ، أنت قلم
سوف اتي
أراك مرة أخرى ليكا 2 5 جرام عراد
العرب الذي كان يشاهد سيلان الأنف جاء 4
أنا أعرف عدم الاستثمار آه تشوا الحدث
لا سكرتير ومن شاركه وودي أثناء الاتصال
عندما يتعلق الأمر بالولادة ، فلنتأخر ، فلنصنع ثريدًا بالأعشاب
اه اه نحن جدا اه
أنا متحمس للغاية على طول الطريق هنا
كنت أرتجف أيضا.
لم أصدق ذلك
بعد وقت طويل مثل هذا 2 Sandman
لأنه مكان لمقابلة الأشخاص الذين تم إزالتهم منه
في الواقع لا يزال
إنه قبل 0 0 الآن ، لذا فهو لا يزال
لا أصدق ذلك
أوه ، أنا متوتر جدًا آه ، العكس هو 4 مرة أخرى
سعيد وطوال الوقت نعم
أهه
[موسيقى]
col2 التجارية تتراجع وهناك الكثير من الاجتماعات
Seokgatap هو خارج الشخصيات الحقيقية PS2 فقط
x yaokakan ثني ص رأسها
انظر إلى الجوكر الأخير ، وصل الألم الفارغ المنخفض
الطلب على المخدرات Bonicanthadeicon
جرانبيرد
قبل المجيء إلى هنا مع الأعضاء
كنت أقوم ببعض التصوير.
أنا معك الآن
اذهب الى دبي
إذا رأيت عرض النافورة ، يمكنك معرفة ذلك
انا اتحدث
هل انت ذاهب مرتين؟
اليس كثيرا نعم اي نوع من رد الفعل هذا
أوه ، وأنا حقا حسود
في الواقع لماذا الآن
أيضا ، لأن ألبوم الحمض النووي يخرج نيكو
في الأصل ، أراد Jee-dong أيضًا أن يأتي معي.
فعلت ، ولكن هذا هو الألبوم ، حان الوقت الآن
Donghae الآن منفردا
حان الوقت الآن
دعنا نخرج ، نعم ، فلنذهب جميعًا معًا
أنا حقا آسف لذلك
4 تأكد من
ماذا تريد تي ان هذا و
يمكن لـ Super Junior أن يجتمعوا معًا
أتمنا لو كان هنالك
وقت متأخر من الليل فائض تشاجي دائرة الرقابة الداخلية
Uh App 1-c 30 خريف وشتاء البحر الشرقي 4
كا آه
حسنًا ، أولاً وقبل كل شيء ، سأراك قريبًا الأسبوع المقبل
على الرغم من أنه يظهر في شكل
إنه لأمر رائع أن يتم إصدار ألبوم منفرد
تهانينا ومرة ​​أخرى
اليوم ، نحن نسجل الآن
إنها حياة حتى اليوم يا هذا صحيح
رأى 4
إنها نشرة
الراحة مع أوامر عفريت ستكون مريحة للغاية
حسنًا 4 نعم
نعم للاستخدام
أو لا تبرد من الداخل إلى الخارج الأرض الأمنية
ما الذي لا يحدث ، ونعم ، هناك الكثير من أصحاب الأهداف
نعم ما الانتهاء من 4 جدارية 8
في مكان ما مثل هذا ، غابة ألتيا دينما
أمشي مرارًا وتكرارًا معجبة بجهاز ضبط الحشو
ينزل كانط 9 مرات مع قرود البابون المعادية
حماس ، أخاف من الشالات في ذاكرتي
بارك جي آه طوال الوقت
بارك يحصل على استفسار عن تعويم n للأمام
لكل باب في الصندوق
في الواقع ، الأغنية نفسها
لا تخرج ، ابق في المنزل
إنها أغنية تسمى اللعب
عرض النافورة أبيض للغاية
إنه أنا ، لذلك أعتقد أننا قريبون
نظرة
أمي هي نحن
عرض نافورة دبي
استمتع بأغنيتنا
أوه
العم الراقص ، القارب يعلق الوقت
أريدك أن تأخذها.
[موسيقى]
تهانينا ، أنا هايد تشارلز
في هذا المكان ، تتحدث عن التأمين ضد السرطان
في القطب الشمالي ، كنت أشتري التلفزيون طوال الوقت
أو أنها مثل حفلة أو موسيقى البوب
اليوم الذي كنت فيه مخطئا
أوه
[موسيقى]
مرة واحدة أريد cynia dna من 5
الأغنية
نعم ، ما نوع الرسالة التي لدينا؟
أي من دعاوى قضيتنا هذا العام؟
لأنها الذكرى العاشرة
شيء 3
آه ، لقد مرت 10 سنوات ، ولكن من الآن فصاعدًا مرة أخرى
أي بداية جديدة أخرى للعد التنازلي
ومن بعد
بهذا الشعور ، بهذه العقلية
هذه السنة
هذا هو معنى الذكرى العاشرة
ما نوع هذه الأغنية ، لذا أه
تم تحديد اسم الألبوم المسمى العد التنازلي
هناك و
العد التنازلي من 10 إلى 19
هذا ما حدث بعد رؤية العلم الثامن
وبالتالي
إذا كنت تفكر في ذلك ، عنواننا
يمكنك
للاستمتاع بـ Performa 3 أكثر
لديك مساعدة
أه لنقطع وعدًا
تراكم القلق
يتم رسم النقاط على هذا النحو
أوو
مثل هذا ، نعم هذه طبقة ds4 5c
نعم آه نعم آه ك فيلو جو
4 آه آه آه آه آه آه آه آه
الثابتة والمتنقلة أليكس توك توك توك
أوه أوه أوه ما هذا آه ماذا
قل
لماذا فيجي كلغة مثال
[موسيقى]
مع الأسف ، عليك أن تعرف ألبوم الحفلة
إنه يوم لم أرغب في اللحاق به في فندق من أربع غرف.
لقد كتبت Anka Neti وجربت شيئًا من الباكال
معالج الباب مثل aya jau al
كعكة تجميع القذرة سكرم ook
شعر التطبيق اجلس جيدًا الآن
هذا المعجبين لا يزال مستمرا
انظر كيف نحن
حتى لو أعلنت شيئًا جديدًا ، مع هذا الوصول ، فإن المعجبين
لا أستطيع مقابلة الناس.
كما ترى ، لدينا الكثير من المحتوى
مصنوع
آمل أن يقدم لك المعجبون هدية
لذلك ، هناك الكثير من التلاشي مع الشركة.
و افكار معي
لقد فعلت الكثير ، لكن هؤلاء كثيرون
هذا ما اخترته من بين الأفكار
سيصدر الآن ، الذي سأريكم إياه
لذا سأريكم المزيد
كان هناك الكثير من الأشياء التي أردتها
4 إذا سنحت لي الفرصة لاحقًا ، سأحاول مرة أخرى
إنها مثل نافذة منبثقة أمامك 5
تريد أن تفعل المزيد من الأشياء
يمكنني تحضيرها وتقديمها لك كهدية
سيكون من الجميل أن يكون
مصطلح تيرا
ووت أشكرك يومًا ما أولاً خذ باين
مصدر اللطف xen على تلك الساق
الحكم ، لذلك لا يوجد هوب
رأيته لأني خرجت للعضوية لماذا تغادر؟
مرحبًا ، هذا ما يجب أن أفعله مع العلم
آه أول
[موسيقى]
ألعب شخصيات موسيقية.
هل هناك صعوبات الآن نعم ، وحتى الآن ، جديدة
أنا أستعد لمسرحية موسيقية
لشهرين
في يوم بدون جدول زمني آخر
اذهب دائمًا إلى غرفة التدريب وتعرف على الشخصية
أنا منغمس تمامًا في الممارسة
لأن
وأثناء الأداء ، المزيد والمزيد
تعتاد عليها وكن مثل هذا الشخص
كن قادرًا على التمثيل والغناء
لأن
حسنًا ، لعب شخصية
أعتقد أنني سأتحسن مع الممارسة
مجرد غناء بطريقة موسيقية فخور عندما
والفرق هو
عندما أغني فقط ، تغني أختي الكبرى
الغناء في مسرحية موسيقية
شخصيتي تغني
مساء الخير
كم تستثمر في مصنع cbe otter الذي ساعد
أوه ، لذلك لمدة 3 أشهر من الأداء
ما يقرب من 5 أشهر من Jeongjo كشخصية
يمكنني العيش
حسنا
أكثر من ذلك بقليل
أنت
قليلا جدا
[موسيقى]
ET Future First ، هناك فاتورة أفضل لفقر الدم
التمييز ترك التلفزيون المهيمن بيديا
دعونا ننجب طفلاً في المسكن ونقوم بتغطيته في غضون أيام قليلة
لأنها كبيرة ، هذه المرة بسبب الأب ستار فيري
الوردي القلب مونيه هو أول ب أم عليه
في الواقع ، على وجه الدقة ، فإن
نحن وشركة SM
أه يجب أن تكون محطة البث متصلة بشكل جيد
أوه ، ثم يمكننا الاستمرار
إنها مشكلة ونحن مستمرون في ذلك
للشعب
شيء يمكننا القيام به جميعًا معًا
إذا كان بإمكانك إظهار المحتوى مثل هذا
أعتقد أنه جيد جدًا 4 لذا
أوه
لا اعرف بعد
إذا استمر المشجعون في الانتظار
برامجنا الممتعة الأخرى
هل يمكنني الحصول على المهارة لمقابلة المن؟
ربما يكون هذا السؤال 4 أو 9 في دبي
في العرب
طفل رضيع 4 بعض قاعدة هيل بوم بيتي
عزيزي
يجعلني أرغب في فعل ذلك كثيرًا
إذا اتصلت للتو ، نعم ، نحن في الواقع كذلك
أي شيء جاهز في أي وقت
نظرة
أوه ، فقط اتصل بي في أي وقت
مراوح تحت ضغط العين
اريد مقابلتك مرة اخرى
أه هناك راديو أو شيء من هذا القبيل
أنت تعرف كل شيء إعلانات Adio TV التجارية 5
إذا كنت تستطيع أن تفعل أشياء كثيرة ، إذا سنحت لك الفرصة
آه قليلا حقا
في سيول ، يوجد الكثير من الأرز 9 2 3
أنا أعمل بجد وأعيش مثل هذا
اعتقدت أنه تم ختم تونجا 4 قليلاً
ما هو ولماذا هو زوج
إذا كنت تشعر بالراحة وتذهب إلى الماء الآن
ما هذا
ما هذا الشعور
نعم احذف ذلك
[موسيقى]
أوو
اه اه
أوه أوه
دعنا نتعرف على الشركة الحقيقية ونأتي
لا توجد إجابة أخيرة للرغبة
4 هذه المرة من خلال عرض النافورة
نريدك أن تغني أغنية
أيضا للكثيرين
الآن بعد أن سمعناها ، يمكننا أيضًا
أنا فخور جدا
جئت للاحتفال بهذا
إنه مقعد ، لكن في الواقع ، سيكون من الأفضل أن يأتي جميع الأعضاء
أن يكون لطيفا
بصفتنا ، هناك أجزاء نأسف عليها
لكن اليوم ، بعد وقت طويل ، الآن المشجعين
كما هو الحال في حالة الاجتماع
أريد أن أحظى بوقت جيد معك
لكنني أريد حقًا أن أعود لاحقًا ، الابن.
دعنا جميعًا نعود لرؤيتك أيضًا
سأفعل ذلك
من فضلك انتظر حتى ذلك الحين شكرا لك
شكرا شكرا لك انا العرب
ملعقة
خاص الخامس بواسطة النائب الحراري
أقول بالحجز
[موسيقى]